une semaine après le début du
déconfinement les autorités avancent
donc prudemment à tâtons les foyers de
reprise de l'épidémie sont surveillés
comme le lait sur le feu
70 car on le disait en coronavirus dans
les écoles depuis la réouverture la
semaine dernière 25 foyers infectieux
dont plusieurs dans des entreprises
notamment des abattoirs école entreprise
le déconfinement en va-t-il trop vite
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir et pour en débattre nous sommes
avec manon lebreton enseignante de
lettres modernes au collège membres de
l'aider constituant à ses côtés denis
jacquet entrepreneurs président de
l'association parrainé la croissance
auteur de pourquoi votre prochain patron
sera chinois aux éditions eyrolles
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
maintenant le breton vous vous êtes donc
on le disait enseignante en zone verte
vous avez fait la rentrée des des
collèges aujourd'hui comment ça s'est
passé est ce que les protocoles
sanitaires ont été respectées difficile
à mettre en place
alors bon soir d'abord oui je viens de
terminer la première journée en
présentiel comme on dit couramment
maintenant face à mes élèves
enfin mes élèves c'est quand même
beaucoup dire on peut dire que oui le
protocole a été globalement plutôt
respectée et pour cause puisque nous
avions convoqué aujourd'hui un seul des
quatre niveaux de koleje c'était les
classes de 5e à castelnaudary dans mon
collège qui était convoqué on a sur 180
élèves
nous avons accueilli 29 élèves
donc moi j'ai vu deux élèves dans une
dans un groupe et trois élèves dans
l'autre donc en réalité ça fait des
semaines maintenant en fait depuis que
emmanuel macron a sorti du chapeau cette
reprise scolaire à la date du 11 mai que
les chefs d'établissements les élus
locaux les enseignants les parents
d'élèves s'arrache les cheveux à qui
mieux mieux pour essayer de faire
la quadrature du cercle c'est à dire
respecter à la fois le protocole
sanitaire
et puis les exigences pédagogiques
minimale enfin tout ce qui peut donner
le moindre sens à cette reprise est bien
on constate que ça fait donc des
semaines qu'on court après les
informations contradictoires les
annonces dans la presse
très peu d'informations directes en
réalité pour nos directions en
particulier tout ça pour finalement
accueillir je vous dis deux élèves dans
une classe trois élèves dans l'autre
alors effectivement on a de la place on
a tout à apprendre de l'espace mais je
peux ajouter pour finir que ces élèves
là ne sont pas ceux qui étaient tant
réclamé par jean michel blanquer requis
disait se préoccuper plus que tous des
élèves décrocheurs de ceux qui n'ont pas
les moyens de se connecter etc
il se trouve que moi parmi les élèves
que j'ai vu aujourd'hui je les avais
tous vu presque à chaque connexion en
classe virtuelle lorsque je les avais
mis en place donc ce ne sont pas les
décrocheurs et c'était évident pour
n'importe qui connaît un peu le
fonctionnement de ces élèves là que si
on laisse le choix aux familles je dis
pas qu'on a eu tort de le faire mais en
tout cas c'était clair que ce n'était
pas pour toucher ce public là denis
jacquet vous vous êtes étonnés par ce
que nous raconte maintenant le breton
une minorité d'élèves qui retourne au
collège est différée un sentiment un
petit peu voilà tout ça pour ça et que
les choses soient extrêmement compliqué
on aurait peut-être dû attendre
septembre pour vous
écoutez en fait il ya sensations
aujourd'hui qu'à force d'avoir mis les
français sous cloche ils deviennent un
peu alors c'est un peu méchant mais au
bout d'un moment il faut bien reprendre
donc pourquoi on peut pas reprendre plus
tard pourquoi c'est mieux dans quinze
jours dans un mois dans trois mois
chaque mois on trouvera une raison de ne
pas reprendre un moment donné il faut
reprendre sa 2 deux ou trois raisons
majeures je le pense je suis pas médecin
si vous regardez quand même sur les 280
mille personnes qui sont mortes dans le
monde chercher les enfants
il n'y en a très peu donc on sait très
bien qu'aujourd'hui cette maladie ne les
atteint pas peu ou extrêmement
légèrement la deuxième chose c'est qu'à
un moment donné si on veut que
l'économie repart pas ce que cette
récession elle va être monstrueuse et
elle va être monstrueuse pour qui pour
les plus fragiles pour ceux qui vont
perdre leur emploi pour les
entrepreneurs qui vont faire faillite
qui font déjà faillite mais un moment
donné il faut que les parents puissent
confier leurs enfants
si on a on va avoir une chance que des
entreprises redémarrent et je vous parle
pas des entreprises du cac40 qu'on veut
toujours flageller mais dont on a
excessivement besoin je vous parle des
petites pme dans tous les territoires et
franchement avoir fait mais comme pour
la crise une telle différenciation entre
le grand test et paris qui était touché
je vous rappelle quand même que dans
plus de 75% des départements on avait
moins de 10 personnes et pour la
majorité d'entre moins de cinq personnes
pour cent mille qui était dans un lit
d'hôpital
on estime qu'aujourd'hui on est
contaminé à 6% c'est-à-dire que 94
d'apple peuvent pour cent de la
population aujourd'hui n'est pas touché
et on veut nous expliquer qu'il faudrait
pas des confinés par retourner à l'école
pas retourner travailler
mais en fait le réveil va être
extrêmement brutal c'est ça que je
n'arrive pas à comprendre ses acquis et
personne pour se réveiller dans ce pays
sur deux choses 1
le fait que à part cuba et la corée du
nord on est aujourd'hui dans des pays
dont on ne peut pas sortir les
frontières sont fermées on est confiné
chez soi on doit s'écrire un automoteur
sortir de chez soi en fait je veux dire
c'est du jamais vu depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale qui étaient autrement
plus dangereuse que ce virus est la
deuxième chose c'est qu'on plonge nos
économies dans une récession et c'est
pas pour faire plaisir aux grandes
entreprises pour qu'elles s'enrichir on
va faire des morts économique des morts
de désespoir des morts de gens qui ne
retrouveront jamais leur emploi demain
et c'est cette je n'arrive toujours pas
à comprendre aujourd'hui maintenant le
breton ça vous choque ce discours moins
il a le mérite de la clarté parce qu'on
a souvent reproché au gouvernement de ne
pas jouer la franchise en disant vous le
faisiez vous y faisiez mentions vous
même tout à l'heure les décrocheurs
alors qu'ils avaient une arrière pensée
économique tout simplement pour que les
parents retournent travailler
est ce que c'est un discours qui est
tout de même audible pour vous que vous
pouvez comprendre
je crois qu'il ya déjà beaucoup de
choses parfois contradictoires
d'ailleurs le discours du gouvernement
on lui reproche pas ce manque de
franchise on lui reproche de dire
absolument tout et son contraire à
chaque fois selon les besoins du moment
donc en réalité plus personne ne prête
sérieusement attention à ce qui est
raconté et c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
dramatique pour revenir sur sur ce que
vous venez de me répondre je crois que
d'abord il faut commencer par distinguer
la question du déconfinement et la
question de la reprise et de la
réouverture des écoles pour la simple
raison que on l'a on l'a dit répété mais
les protocoles et tous les spécialistes
de ces protocoles de déconfinement les
spécialistes sanitaires et scientifiques
disent depuis longtemps que le principe
à suivre dans un cas de déconfinement
c'est qu'on trouvera en dernier les
établissements qui ont fermé en premier
or nous avons commencé par fermer les
établissements scolaires parce qu'ils
étaient potentiellement des foyers de
diffusion du virus et donc il aurait dû
en toute logique être mal an c'est peu
mais j'ai une question quand même à vous
poser il ya une tribune de d'éminents
pédiatre le chef du service pédiatrie de
robert debré
ils ont publié une pub une tribune la
semaine dernière dans le quotidien du
médecin
appelant les parents à remettre les
enfants à l'école affirmant qu'il n'y
avait absolument aucun danger ni pour
les uns ni pour les autres les enfants
contaminés qu'on a mis à part dont
contaminé l'été par les adultes et pas
l'un vers ce qu'est ce que vous répondez
tout de même alors je vais finir de dire
de répondre à la première chose sûre
c'est la question des tribunaux on en a
tellement en ce moment qu'ils disent là
aussi tout et son contraire que si on
devait caler notre comportement et les
doctrines gouvernementale sur les
tribunes on serait pas sorti de
l'auberge amanda lear
donc je n'ai pas connaissance de celle
ci en particulier mais ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que en tout cas le
conseil scientifique dont le
gouvernement se réclamer pendant un
certain temps avait comme vous le savez
préconisé un retour en septembre donc
pour vous répondre monsieur ça fait
quand même une raison non négligeable
d'attendre septembre et je parle là de
la réouverture des écoles
vous me répondez que les écoles doivent
rouvrir pour renvoyer les parents au
travail c'est effectivement sans doute
dans cette optique là qu emmanuel macron
à d'emblée associé déconfinement et
réouverture des écoles
sauf que là aussi c'est un échec total
je vous dis que moi aujourd'hui alors
d'une part les élèves
au delà de au dessus de la 4e sont ne
sont il n'est pas question de les faire
revenir au collège pour l'instant donc
qu'en est il de leurs parents je vous
garantis que tous les élèves de
quatrième ne peuvent pas garder tout
seul et par ailleurs moi j'ai reçu je
vous dis aujourd'hui uniquement des
classes de 5e
les élèves ne peuvent pas tous retourner
tous les jours à l'école puisque on fait
des petits groupes et encore heureux
puisque sinon on annulerait totalement
le bénéfice du confinement est donc en
réalité les parents sont de la même
façon confrontés à la difficulté de
faire garder leurs enfants moi pour
l'exemple de mon collège et bien un jour
sur par semaine ils sont pris en charge
quand ils le souhaitent et le résultat
ça n'est pas le cas et ce qu'on constate
de toute façon je voulais dit c'est que
là les normes les cra gens que
l'écrasante majorité des parents ne
renvoient pas leurs enfants à l'école
c'est là aussi quand on l'a vu
au moment des municipales une forme de
grève civique pour moi qui s'exprime de
cette façon là et c'est la défiance
envers la parole gouvernementale et
l'action gouvernementale qui trouve ici
une expression absolument criante c'est
je le répète vraiment préoccupant pour
l'avenir de notre pays que de voir à
quel point les français n'ont plus
confiance dans l'action de couverts de
neige à kege voulez vous faire réagir ce
que le temps passe sur l'entreprise
également le déconfinement sauce fait
dans les entreprises également avec un
protocole sanitaire imposée très strict
pour les entreprises vous craignez vous
justement tant qu'entrepreneur des mini
foyer qui ressurgissent dans des
entreprises au contraire il faut y aller
désormais renvoyer les gens au travail
ils auront du sang sur les mains demain
il faudra qu'ils en assument la
responsabilité
je le répète 280 mille morts sur 7
milliards d'individus
donc on sait pas le choléra c'est pas la
peste mais c'est par ebola c'est parce
qu'on a connus avant on ne comprend pas
pourquoi pour un taux de mortalité aussi
faible qui ne se remarquera même pas
dans les statistiques dans dix ans on
puisse condamner à mort économiquement
non pas les entreprises les salariés
ceux qui vont perdre leur job dans les
territoires petits et moyens moi je
venais d'un petit territoire rural avec
une ville moyenne
aucun des emplois perdus ces trente
dernières années ne s'est jamais recréé
on n'a pas une crise de cette nature là
les emplois même dans les terrains
agricoles pour faire des mauvais john
mon mec d'honneur de l'engrais ça ne
repousse pas moi où j'ai vécu toute ma
vie toute mon enfance tous les emplois
perdus ces trente dernières années n'ont
disparu
et vous savez qui est le principal
employeur aujourd'hui de la ville de
naissance c'est l'hôpital donc il faut
un moment donné comprendre que est-ce
que vous avez vu les les exemplaires et
là je rejoins madame sur la question de
la défiance ce gouvernement est un des
pires sur la gestion de la crise dans le
monde
voilà je veux dire les choses sont
extrêmement claires quand j'entends
castaner nous donner des leçons sur la
responsabilité lui qui apparaissait dans
des vidéos sur youtube
éméché avec sa maîtresse au loto il ya
quelques mois paris ça me fait rigoler
ces gens-là nous donne des leçons on n'a
pas de masque tout le monde savait même
quelqu'un qui n'est pas médecin que les
masques étaient la clé hong kong taiwan
du vietnam moins 200 morts chacun
pourquoi parce que les gens portaient
des masques et ne peuvent pas infecter
les autres aujourd'hui on soit dans nos
entreprises des guides de 40 50 80 pages
pour nous expliquer comment réaffecter
un espace et ne pas et maintenir la
distanciation on a deux millions
d'entreprises de moins de 10 personnes
elles ont 80 mètres carrés de locaux
vous faites comment pour faire du
télétravail pour ses boîtes là vous
faites comment pour les faire revenir
cette maladie ne tue pas ce qui a tué
c'est le manque d'organisation
25000 25 mille lits en allemagne cinq
mille en france ce qui a tué les gens
c'est que le système de santé et soit en
faillite
on les a abandonnés depuis 30 ans et
qu'on ne puisse pas accueillir les gens
dans de bonnes conditions
si on avait les lie le personnel les
équipements aujourd'hui une partie des
gens qui sont décédés aujourd'hui ne
serait pas mort et franchement ne pas
renvoyer à l'école dans les entreprises
dans des zones où je vous le rappelle en
france dans 70 % des départements je le
répète il y a moins de cinq personnes
pour cent mille dans un lit d'hôpital
c'est juste une catastrophe donc pensé
pour une fois oublié paris pensé à la
province penser au petit territoire
ils sont en train de mourir quand un
entrepreneur moeurs ce sont 4 5 ou de 10
salariés qui meurt et qu'ils ne
retrouveront jamais leur emploi donc
qu'on m'explique que c'est pas bien été
confinés comme ça qu'on peut pas faire
confiance au gouvernement qu aujourd'hui
j'ai reçu que 5 ou 10 eve très bien mais
c'est quoi la solution d'attendre le
mois prochain pourquoi ça sera mieux le
mois prochain et pourquoi pas mieux le
mois d'après il faut bien démarrer un
moment donné on a construit sur un autre
point il vous fait des réponses très
longue tous les deux on s'est un peu
compliqué répondait rapidement s'il vous
plaît oui non mais j'en doute
je pense que là où nous serons d'accord
c'est que le bon moment pour le
déconfinement c'est toujours le plus tôt
possible pour vous comme pour moi et moi
j'ai hâte de pouvoir retrouver mes
élèves dans des conditions qui s'y
prêtent
la question c'est qu'est ce qui permet
un des confinant dans de bonnes
conditions
or à l'heure actuelle nous n'avons pas
avancé sur ce point là
je repense aux annonces de olivier
ferrand qui nous disait il ya quelques
semaines que pour permettre un
déconfinement dans de bonnes conditions
nous allions augmenter progressivement
la quantité de tests effectués et qu'on
allait augmenter la capacité à 700 mille
tests par semaine aujourd'hui le
déconfinement a commencé depuis une
semaine et on est très très loin
puisqu'on est à peine à la moitié de ce
qui a été annoncé dans les derniers
chiffres qu'il a donnée autrement dit on
ne se donne pas les moyens de de
permettre à ceux des cuviers de
confinement d'avoir lieu en laissant en
mettant les français en sécurité et ils
sentent cette insécurité et c'est pour
ça qu'ils sont extrêmement réticents à y
aller et je pense que de toute façon
tout le monde conviendra aussi que
l'économie elle et c'était problématique
primordial pour tout le monde mais que
ça ne servira à rien de descons fine et
n'importe comment et de devoirs confinés
dans deux semaines ou un mois
voilà merci merci à tous les deux mais
non le breton enseignante donc denis
jacquet entrepreneurs d'avoir été avec
nous pour débattre sur ce déconfinement
mercier vous